bonjour à tous
on se retrouve sur cette série pour les
sur les joueurs français et je voulons
finir en fait un peu avec les joueurs
avant le avant le 20e siècle et donc je
veux faire cette petite vidéo sur le
joueur qu'on connaît sous le nom d' le
gall donc c'est un joueur qui était
breton mais qui venaient jouer donc à
paris au café de la régence et qui était
le meilleur joueur français de l'époque
donc sûrement un des meilleurs joueurs
au monde et qui a même été donc le
professeur de philidor est
malheureusement en fait on n'a pas de
trace de ces partis à part ce fameux
match donc je pense que tout le monde
connaît donc je vous montrais la partie
c'était parti donc de le gall contre
saint bris et donc ça commence comme une
défense philidor oui je vous ces 4es
avec les noirs ils jouent le coup pas
terrible h6 c'est pas terrible pourquoi
parce que certes on ne vide kg 5 ne
s'était pas tellement une menace et donc
il était possible de simplement se
développer il faut 7 pour ensuite médoc
et valiant les petits et 6 et blanc
jouent kg 5
alors à ce moment là on pourra toujours
ok et défendre f7 si besoin bon toujours
est il il a fait si ce qu'avait laissé
trois coups de développement et la fouge
et quatre clowns cavaliers mais
évidemment mauvais coup mauvais coup
pourquoi parce que il ya le fort coup
kelly prend 2,5 dessus donc on laisse la
dame emprise et sur foot rendez un fou
prend à vii à ce moment là et chaque le
roi n'a qu'une seule case of 7
et qui a eu des cinq matches donc voilà
un joli tableau de maths et
et fin de la partie donc le match de le
gall c'est ça mais qu'est ce que ça nous
apprend en fait surtout que un clouage
sur la dame n'est absolument pas un
clouage absolue contrairement cinq loges
sur le roi ou la pièce n'a pas l'aura de
bouger alors on donne rarement notre
dame
mais on connaît dans pleins d'ouverture
genre de choses et donc on va revoir un
peu certaines choses ou justement cloud
est comme ça en fait
l'interdît pas aux cavaliers de 3,2
bouger et pouvoir le coup comme le gala
jeu qui a éprouvé 5 par exemple
donc là dans la partie on a vu les prix
la dame bien évidemment ça c'était mieux
de reprendre juste lecavalier après
dames seront fou et ben les blancs ont
quand même ont quand même un peu plus
mais un développement une position
gagnante
bon après c'est toujours mieux que de se
faire mater vous me direz mais mais
voilà du coup du coup je peux montrer
quelques variantes
dans lesquelles ça arrive c'est fou j'ai
quatre soit mauvais ou quoi par exemple
par exemple a lieu quatre des cinq donc
scandinave
puis on prend 2 me prend qu'elle et ses
3 c'est le coût normal on se développe
en gagnant at en attaquant la dame est
disons d'amd 8 alors bien évidemment en
général dames à 5 et le coût principal
hmm hmm d'amd si c'est un autre coup
mais damas un koala c'est le coût très
joué que kiev 12 ans dans tous ces blitz
en général mesdames des huit écoutez
c'est pas si mauvaise pas terrible en
ramena dame à la maison mais bon car
l'asnl avait joué avec des trucs à
roanne avec une olympiade donc c'est pas
non plus débile cavaliers f3 cavalli et
6 10 ont poussé quatre et la voilà je
montre un exemple une logique à ce très
mauvais mauvais pourquoi parce qu'il ya
donc deux options soit en fait fou prend
f7 très bien on dit villeroy et qui
avait lieu cinq échecs et ont fait une
fourchette sur le roi est sûre le fou
donc le roi doit bouger le coup d'après
on prend g4 kelly prend dame prend et on
a gagné un pion d'ailleurs sur flu g4 on
pourra jouer le coup de le gall quelque
parti qu'ils avaient lieu 5 qui est très
bien aussi
puisque vous prendrez un bien sûr serait
perdant à cause de fou première sept
matches du coup il faudra absolument jeu
faut aussi et après fou prend pions cran
on voit que la positio noir est très
mauvaise
parce que ça le structure de pions
mauvais développement le fouet fuite il
va falloir faire g6 rouge et c'est au
mieux pour le développer et les blancs
sont très bien donc c'était aussi une
option mais voilà ces tests exemple la
voyez par vous issifou g4 serait juste
très mauvais donc ce serait mieux de
développer pendant que le four en f 5
puis faire aussi sans suite ou quelque
chose comme ça un autre exemple un autre
exemple bien connu ça peut être dans le
grand bain dame par exemple des 4 donc
on reprend 0,1 des quatre premiers coups
des 5 c 4 6
donc voilà on renforce le centre qui a
laissé trois cavaliers pts 6 et par
exemple ou g5 donc la foule 7 c'est le
camp principal mais
certains joueurs commencent par kelly b
17 donc pas mauvais mais on peut dire
oui mais c'est l'air bizarre parce que
les noirs perdre pernin pions en d5
après cavalli prend puisque le cavalier
de cissé quand même cloud mais voilà
c'est encore une fois ces histoires de
clouage qui n'est pas absolu et donc on
peut simplement reprendre le cavalier et
surtout prend des huit ont fait faux
bond et quatre échecs et en fait on voit
le problème du roi donc qui est attaqué
et pour pour éviter l'échec en objet de
rendre la dame nous mêmes avec dom d2
sur quoi les noirs peuvent prendre des
deux ou simplement prendre d'abord en
des 8 et on reprendra ensuite en d2 et
puis les balais nord une pièce de plus
quoi une fois qu'ils ont compris que les
bleus ont repris la dame
enfin le fou les noirs restent à dire
qu'amélie de plus un autre exemple dans
ce genre de 2
le truc c'est pas un peu 4 disons qu'à
laisser six cavaliers
trois des six des quatre cavaliers psy
ce qui a laissé trois rouges et quatre
n'ont jusque là rien à dire c'est très
bien parler demain c'est jouable et les
noirs en fait en gros mettre la pression
sur le centre donc on peut faire flouer
3 qui est un coup très bien mais et des
joueurs qui jouent des 5 et une petite
idée parents histoire cavaliers e52
prendre le cavalier alors l'idée c'est
que si la les noirs prennent la dame ont
fait fourbissent 5 et sur ses 6 on peut
prendre est maintenant menacé cette
honda s'est éventuellement pions grand
bessette mais bon c'est ça de plus fort
et sur parme se déprendre 5 on fasse et
cet échec une nouvelle fois les noirs
doivent vendre la dame on reprend là ah
bon c'est pas une vente ou les danses
ont foutu ils vont reprendre 17 on va
prendre le fond d un et ils vont prendre
ces sept donc c'est égalité matérielle
jusque un peu mieux niveau structure
pour les blancs mais voilà c'est juste
des exemples je vous montre
des extensions ce maître de le gall on
va dire où le clouage de clouage et bien
et pas si bien que juste parfois faire
attention
disons aux 4,5 bon je veux mettre une
position hasard kf3 kaïs et 6 ils ont
poussé 4 l'italienne bondé 6 bon en
général décide c'est pas terrible on
sait vaut mieux jouer cavalier m6
ouf ou c5 et c'est écrit noir mais là
c'est juste pour mon petit exemple donc
là les blancs peuvent faire des quatre
qui est très bien et admettons fuji 4
voilà là par contre faut surtout pas
faire le fou prend f7 roi prend f ça tu
es kg 5 6 ans oui ma super je donne
échec et j'attaque le fou donc je veux
regagner le fukuda près j'aurais gagné
un pion pourquoi pas ce qu'il ya dans le
rang et là c est noir qu'il ya du
matériel
parce que si on prend la dame ils
prennent un autre à ce moment là ils ont
compris le fou et si on fait le bilan on
a comme une pièce de moins donc là ça
marche pas du tout donc c'est pas
automatique que ça marche le foot pro f
7 et qui avait jugé cinq ou cabello 5 ou
quoi mais
mais voilà faut toujours garder et faire
attention quand vous faites un clouage
comme ça ça peut juste ne pas marché du
tout donc là en l'occurrence dans la
position comme ses trois et c'est quand
même très bien pour les blancs qui ont
construit leurs bons centres experts
externes je dis pas que c'est une bonne
ligne pour les noirs mais juste on peut
pas réputé avec juste supra f7 et kg 5
bon voilà c'était juste courte vidéo sur
sur le gall sur son ce match sympa après
comme je l'aï déjà signalé dans d'autres
vidéos le truc c'est comme les joueurs à
l'époque ne notait pas les parties on
n'a pas de trace de son jeu mais il
était vraiment considéré comme un très
bon joueur et
bon voilà il ya cette partie là qu' une
miniature très connu mais j'imagine
qu'il dut faire des parties sympa mais
malheureusement voilà donc on se
retrouvera ensuite pour parler de deux
autres joueurs français
et puis après on passera aux joueurs un
peu plus moderne donc à partir du 20e
siècle avec ali kinés et les autres à
aller à plus